[Music]
i have a new sport
i have a new sport and it's not bullet
ball i have a new sport for us um
the sport is
world championship of tag remember tag
that you played as a kid yes
yes
this
is change dad
this is a massive one gn
athletes
check this [ __ ] out
we've seen sodom and used that base of
the mountain as a starting point before
that uses the outside ring of the court
to chase all the way around and ruji is
not panicking i'm surprised this is
british by the way do you think that
maybe we've run out of sports and maybe
we should stop making new sports
oh
have you seen the
the
the mongolian one where they uh they're
on horseback
and they just throw a dead goat into a
hole
what
yeah
i'll show you that one just yet
but he hits a pole there over the
sisters and he's got his face up again
i'm surprised how many people knew this
existed professional tag yeah yeah this
has been a while but he's not cutting
down not cutting down the space and
sodamon's away
oh
okay
you know what
i might like this
doesn't stop him he's got another point
to lead off for the hollywood free
runners
the hollywood free runners
yeah they have teams and [ __ ]
you're probably not
sure both of them look like they bailed
their both seth and kyle but kyle got
away with the invasion
so are all these guys like parkour guys
pretty much obviously i just figured
something out
it ends well
even when he's eating platforms he's
picking up points and evasions
women's pro spanking what is that
we yes uh there's that's also thing okay
give me that too i want to see these
sports
all right we're doing a sports day got
it it's sports ball days
so here's here's the one with the with
the dead goat
okay hollywood free runners evader
1-0 hollywood free freerunners
athletes ready
what's the last one the the the
second all right
closer got it closer got it so the so so
the first guy
gets to go first like gets through gets
like a head start right is that what i'm
saying
um
yeah let's start from the differences
and it's given chase three so i guess i
look at the replays to make sure that uh
we attacked him
up evading all right who's gonna win the
white dude or the black dude black dude
blackjack yeah cause there's a chaser
because if not he'll shoot him
crap black dude comes out just shoots
him and tags him
ready here we go here we go here comes
dale smith looking to track down david's
vascon celos and he skirts around the
cube decides to go centered on
blowing them out of the water blowing
them out of the water blowing them out
of the water oh oh oh oh
oh wow okay i'm in the professional tag
now i am this is my new favorite sport
is is there like a fantasy league
i doubt it i mean we could probably
you know make it benefit
[Applause]
the flores lava is actually a show on
netflix and i've seen it and it's stupid
like he was being tracked down and then
that useful mountain really gave him the
advantage in the latter seconds
super calm super collected here okay
hear me out here
same sport
but they get knives
oh you have to stick it in them yeah
it's gotta like be in them okay what do
you think
i mean
you're how many rounds are we doing like
that could get bloody and slippery
i mean as many as it takes right
yeah i think is it like whoever survives
wins or
like how do you determine who who is
because you can get stabbed a couple of
times and still yeah
i mean if you get stabbed you lose that
round but if you can keep playing you
keep playing
and you just have to like now do we lead
the knives in and you run around with
the knives jiggling everywhere that's up
to you
okay
it's like if you pull it out it's going
to start bleeding more someone says can
you throw the knives no you can't throw
the knife that would be ridiculous come
on
now hold on hold on hold on if you throw
and you miss you're out
all right i'll allow it all right that's
fine that way you can get one of those
right off the start
your tactics and execute them to the
best of your ability without anxiety or
anything getting in your way
chase iv gnf evading one all
come on
athletes ready
how do i get a professional tag shirt
i'm a big fan of i'm a big fan of the
hollywood free runners and i would like
one of their shirts please all right let
me see hollywood freerunners thank you
paulie
wood
zacky team captain for the hollywood
freerunners goes over to the tilted cube
tracking down vasconcellos who just
shuffles under the mountain but builds
up a bit of speed over the front line a
nice little jump up to the mountain oh
oh ouch
ouch he got [ __ ] did you see that
yeah look at this look at this
little jump up to them
oh
oh that hurts that is a big big fall
from omar zaki and he's up and there is
no way that he's going to catch him from
there oh he is [ __ ] up that's a savage
also uh no shirts they don't have shirts
they really don't that's ridiculous they
don't have sharks for sale
are there women that do this or is this
just a man's sport it's just a man's
part i think wow that's sexist they
should do this but like without shirts
on
so we put some more a couple spots all
right so this is the one with the goat
yeah this is the one with the goat
there's a lot of injuries in this
well that's what are they doing explain
so they get a dead carcass and it's like
polo but you're with a dead goat
and you just toss it in a hole like that
[Music]
mongolian oh my god
[Music]
kobe
some guys get trampled some guys oh
think there's one where this guy gets
trampled by the horses like
one after the other
all right man this is [ __ ] insane
why is this a sport
uh because mongolians needed a sport
oh the booty slapping contest i have
seen i think i've played it on the show
before
that was a week
what what is that that's are you even
trying do you want to go professional
oh come on
what is this [ __ ] amateurs
that was weak
there we go yeah now we're [ __ ]
talking
i agree with leo's right they have pants
on that doesn't seem fair
cole horace you spank like a girl
there we go that's a good one see the
vibration yeah
bender over dummy
no come on
you lose you lose already
okay guys i'm going to be honest with
you i don't think these people are
taking this seriously no no is there any
[ __ ] real people they're going to try
yeah i think we're going to stop no come
on now what is this
this is [ __ ]
black get up can get
well it better be ready for something
more now i'm starting to think these
guys aren't even really trying to win
no no
the one in the red over there she can
probably slap like a champ oh i get it
it's hot that's fine but when i watch a
sport i watch for the sport and these
people
aren't even [ __ ] trying
like you've seen the professional
slapping contest right oh those ones go
like those are [ __ ] legit